mr speaker we were so relieved to hear
the secretary of state was going to
announce a scheme to allow ukrainian
refugees a route to safety after weeks
of delay
but a press release is not a plan
and we are really deeply concerned about
the lack of urgency he went on tv
yesterday to claim that ukrainians could
be here by sunday but he's just told us
that they will still need a visa under
the current application process these
are 50 page forms that have to be
completed online asking people who have
fled with nothing to find an internet
cafe to upload documents they don't have
water bills mortgage documents to prove
who they are
the home office has been incredibly slow
in issuing these visas as of this
morning only 4 000 have been issued we
are lagging way behind the generosity of
other countries we could simplify this
process today we could keep essential
checks but drop the excessive
bureaucracy he knows it why hasn't it
been done for weeks the british people
have been coming forward in large
numbers to offer help it's been moving
heartwarming to see the decency and
spirit on display in every corner of
this country but can he clarify what
exactly the government will be doing
especially in relation to matching
families to sponsors because on his tour
of the tv studios he suggested several
times that people who are willing to
sponsor a ukrainian family need to come
to the government with the name of that
family who will then rub a stamp it he
can't seriously be asking ukrainian
families who are fleeing vladimir putin
who've left their homes with nothing to
get onto instagram and advocate
themselves in the hope that a british
family might notice them is this
genuinely the extent of this scheme
surely there's a role for the secretary
of state in matching ukrainian families
to their sponsors not just a diy asylum
scheme where all he does is take the
credit can he please clarify what the
government's role is going to be
there's been a lack of urgency to get
people here and there's still a lack of
urgency to ensure we support them when
they do
my honourable friend and i spoke with
council leaders
earlier today they stand ready and
willing to help why hasn't anyone from
his department picked the phone up to
them i spoke to charities last week who
he will ask to act as sponsors
they are acutely aware that the people
who are coming
will be quite unlike previous refugees
two million people are on the march
children alone
mums with very young kids older people
the brutal reality of what's happening
in ukraine is that working age people
have stayed behind to fight now they
will have health care needs they'll need
school places maternity care social care
one council leader told me today that
his city which traditionally plays a
major role in welcoming refugees has
only
nine secondary school places available
has it not occurred to him until this
point to pick up the phone to leaders
like him before he went into the tv
studios and promised the earth these
charities and council leaders are the
same people who stepped up during covid
they spin gold out of thread every
single day and what is keeping them
awake at night right now is how we do
right by people and keep them safe it
was only a few months ago that the home
office placed a child into a hotel in
sheffield
that they had been told was unsafe
without even bothering to tell the
council and he fell out of a window and
died
will he ensure that every council is
contacted by close of play today will he
work with them to do the vetting checks
that are needed they're experts in
safeguarding children will he not just
trust them but support them will he put
a safety net in place in case a
placement breaks down
his department over the weekend
confirmed that families who are left
homeless in that situation will not be
able to claim for housing costs under
universal credit surely that can't be
true surely we are not going to ask
people who fled bombs and bullets to lie
homeless on the streets of britain i
suspect mr speaker he has felt as
ashamed as i have to watch how this
government has closed the door to people
who need our help people have been he
shakes his head people have been turned
back at calais they've been left
freezing by the roadside with their
children we've had planes leaving
neighboring nato countries packed to the
rafters except those to london because
this government has turned people away
the british people who've come forward
have shown that we are a far better
country than their government but unless
he gets a plan together a real plan not
just a press release all he is
effectively announcing is plans to fail
the people of ukraine twice over
he said today that they have our total
admiration and they do but they need
more than that they need our total
support